if you've ever been to the silverton
you've probably seen their giant fish
take right when you walk in right
occasionally you can catch a mermaid
swimming by but did you know you can
actually learn to be a mermaid for a day
jillian takes us to mermaid school so
let's check it out
hey you guys yes i am living out my
dream of becoming a mermaid for a day
and you can too well the kids can we're
here at the silverton and they actually
offer a mermaid school for kids and let
me tell you i am having so much fun with
the fin on i'm here with tana and
kristen thank you guys for having us out
here let's talk about what it means to
be a mermaid for a day tell us a little
bit about the mermaid school of course
so we have our program running right now
it's our mermaid school you can come and
swim as a mermaid so it's for kids ages
seven to twelve we do it four days a
week right now we allow up to six kids
at a time so it's a very specialized
program they get to come in and there's
three kids per one instructor
they get a little warm-up session
stretch them out and then they get into
the water with a mermaid tail our lovely
instructors will teach them how to swim
around and kick properly in the tail and
then when they are all done they
actually get a behind the scenes tour of
the aquarium and get a closer look at
all of our fish oh my gosh this is so
much fun speaking of fish they are
everywhere in the tank i think it's so
funny can jump in and actually swim
alongside them and tana let's talk about
it i mean being a mermaid is everyone's
dream how fun is it to be a mermaid here
at the silverton well i grew up a
synchronized swimmer so i've always
loved the water so this job was my dream
job i just love swimming with the fish
and hanging out with all the kids well i
feel like a kid at heart today that's
for sure and these classes fill up
quickly so you guys already opened up
dates for july and august how can people
sign up yes so you can go to the
silverton website you can sign up online
a lot of the dates are already sold out
so if you're looking to do it do it soon
i know the weekends went very quickly
that's why we added two more days on so
wednesdays fridays saturdays and sundays
you can sign up to come in and if you've
ever been to the silverton you notice
the tank it's the first thing you see
when you walk in the mermaid swim by
it's so fun no matter what age you are
just remember growing up here and that
was always the most exciting thing so
we're getting ready to head into the
tank and i'm gonna actually get to swim
alongside the fish here so you guys
thanks for getting me prepped i have my
fins ready to go and i can't wait to
jump in the water also it's a little
chilly so they do offer these body suits
if you're a wimp like me and want to
stay warm so i will check back in with
you guys in a little bit i'm working on
being a mermaid for a day and i'll see
you guys soon